what's up guys it is Thursday Wednesday
where are we where are we in this week
and to think you called me
unprofessional I'm Dan I'm Jen and it's
up against what use kicking things off
today blue hole the developers of player
unknowns battlegrounds have revealed
some details on the upcoming desert map
oh that's a hot terrible I wonder if
they'll have new guns
sandy Kia that barely held together uh
something about cactus the new map is
called Miramar and it includes
industrial areas beach towns arid desert
land and what looks like not a lot of
places to hide in the flora Blue Hole
posted on the steam forums the unique
terrain and dense urban areas of Miramar
will create a new battle royale
experience where the old strategies may
no longer work and new tactics are
required there are at least eight major
cities in the new map that each feature
different landmarks and require
different strategies as you've already
heard there's a new vehicle and a new
weapon the win 94 for you to enjoy the
final test round for the new map is
apparently going to be playable sometime
this month before pub G's 1.0 release so
stay tuned to games but and as soon as
we know you'll know monster hunter world
is ensuring that those of us keen to
play it cannot relax its January release
date is looming that's right capcom has
also revealed details on the upcoming
beta the beta on ps4 kicks off this
Saturday December 9th at 9 a.m. Pt and
runs until December 12 you'll need a
PlayStation Plus subscription to take
pot as well as about six gigabytes of
space free on your console folio
gigabytes you can test out three quests
across two environments the ancient
forest and wild spy a waste where you
can hunt the great jag rest engine F and
the rock-headed birth all quests can be
completed solo or with up to 3 other
players and Capcom has said that anyone
who completes the missions will earn
some useful bonus items when the full
game releases Monster Hunter world is
out on ps4 and Xbox one on January 26th
with the PC version to follow sometime
after finally a new portal game has been
announced but it might not be the portal
game you're looking for maybe it is the
new game entitled bridge constructor
portal is a crossover between portal and
bridge constructor yeah look you
probably picked that out on your own the
game tasks you with getting a truck from
one side of the screen to the other just
like in vanilla bridge constructor
although the
time you'll be using portals to get to
your goal the game is coming to PC and
Mobile on December 20th and according to
the developers Clark stone software and
head-up games console versions will
follow in early 2018 that is everything
we've got a few today thanks so much for
joining us once again do remember to
leave us your thoughts down in that
comment section and we'll be back same
time tomorrow
either Jesus oh boy you good you got it
[Music]